hello and welcome to agenda from
brussels tension continues to rise as
the crisis in ukraine intensifies as
vladimir putin continues with his plans
to absorb crimea to the russian
federation europe and americas and
united to impose a new wave of sanctions
that could [ __ ] the russian economy
and send it into diplomatic isolation
the ushering of a new cold war or can a
diplomatic solution be found kicking
things off on wednesday an extraordinary
meeting of the conference of presidents
open to all members of parliament also
attending will be the president of the
european council airman van rompuy and
representatives of the commission
they'll all discuss the recent european
council meeting and the first round of
russian sanctions that came by way of
travel bans on russian officials also on
the same day meps will no doubt look on
with interest when president obama
visits brussels for the first time for
eu u.s summit
so what do you want to be when you grow
up well that's a question that we're all
asked since we're about this high but
for those dreaming of being say a
politician on friday it's the second
time this month that parliament opens
its doors to some 500 students across
member states to get a taste of what
meps really do they'll get to debate in
the chamber conduct committee meetings
just like this one
and they can also try their hand at
drafting reports could these be the
leaders of the next generation have fun
today and thanks for listening to me
thank you
and that's all we have for this agenda
take care and enjoy the week